hello everyone uh round of applause
who's hungover round of applause who
needs more caffeine round of applause
who's ready for some barbecue there you
go hello everybody my name is Colt
McAnlis and I am your final speaker for
today thank God oh sorry no oh that is
true that's true yeah sorry and today
we're going to talk about something near
and dear to my heart a continuous
integration for Android performance
asleep yet anybody nobody okay don't
worry we'll get there again that's why i
asked the hungover and the caffeinated
part first um by the way there's only
some days you get to wake up and make
sure that your shirt matches your slides
it's a design decision I made today um
here's the rub with being an Android
developer we're also Android users right
which means we implicitly know what it
feels like for an app to not be
performant right we know when we grab
our phone and we start scrolling and
it's just hichi that that's not cool
right we know what exactly what it feels
like to not be able to get your data
fast enough or see that little stupid
spinner every time you open the app we
understand that anger right admit it
raise your round of applause if you've
uninstalled an app because it was not
performing up to your expectations
and guess what you need to remember that
feeling right of the billions of users
on mobile today they all do that that is
actually why we like to say that perf
matters right for the individuals who
then go to uninstall their application
because of performance we found a
correlation of seventy-three percent
they're more likely to go give negative
feedback in the store because of it and
in fact they will further go on to tell
their friends how crappy their
experience was with your application
just because of performance the
correlation is higher for negativity on
performance than anything else from that
standpoint performance is actually a
business feature more than it is a bunch
of bald guys yelling about enums on the
internet I see some of y'all in here
I'll get to you in a minute that's why
we like to say that performance is is is
hard yeah you know I'm I'm sorry
I know I just realized something I'm
given a California keynote in Texas
all right now let's try this again we're
going to start this a top here I came
here to do two things today number ones
to kick ass and number two's to give a
keynote my keynotes almost over now
listen here we got two things on the
agenda besides at keynote performance
barbecue listen performance is hard
y'all that's not translated pretty well
in my opinion performance is hard look
at all this crap you got to do right
first off there is just a jizz ilion of
devices out there you got worried about
I mean people got devices attached to
the candle touch to the watches now I
even saw in cavenders someone had a
smart boot don't know what it does but
it's out there and you got to worry
about performance on it right and then
the problem is if he does have a problem
with his smart boot when he's out in the
fields hunt quail you can't repo the
performance problem little do you know
that there was a quail attached to his
boot when he experienced that hitch eNOS
that don't mean he ain't gon give you a
bad review for it so as a developer it's
hard for you to find these performance
bugs right can I get a hell yeah
oh that's pretty hmm we're gonna milk
that one in addition to that when you do
get the bug and can finally actually
repoed a damn thing you got to go do it
manually you got to hit the button and
run the tool and get the information and
figure it out and then hand it back to
someone else who tells you you're stupid
because there wasn't a quail in the
testing environment I keep a
well-stocked cupboard a quail by the way
it's a delicious animal you ain't been
quail hunting this season the issue with
that though is that even though you do
this manual profile and the tools are
hard I mean listen they're more complex
than a snub-nosed bull inside of a
cotton field I mean come on now so even
and when you can do the manual profile
you got to go through all this
to try to get through it and the issue
the reason that the tools are so complex
is that the daggone systems complex
right I mean we're talking about
stacking a bowl on top of a Hayfield
inside of a barn you can't just do that
you can't just walk in one day and be
like I'm gonna stack some Bulls know you
got a plan it then you got to get some
diagrams you got to get Chet there and
Chet's got to talk about it and then he
tells you you can't check in your damn
code because it ain't compliant the
readability look I just want to stack a
damn bull today okay but you can't do it
because it's too complex and that's all
right I can forgive that but performance
is difficult cuz of it and of course the
final problem is actually going in and
making the damn changes to fix the
performance issues that you realize the
smart boot was having without stupid
quail out in the field stupid quails now
don't get me wrong we're here in Texas
and we enjoy a little manual labor am i
right gonna get hell yeah wait first off
who here is actually from Texas
alright who's here from Oklahoma
y'all go back
yo Arkansas Oh with y'all right bless
your heart honey bless your heart oh I'm
sorry Oklahoma alright so this is the
reason the performances dadgum heart
it's too difficult to build our
applications in a performant manner
because of these things and I got to
tell you what this is the whole reason
we started the Android performance
patterns product Joanna this is where
you're supposed to clap and get them all
started no no just do it now fleet thank
you good helps hard to find this is the
reason we started this whole initiative
because it's too damn hard to get the
performance of your applications right
and we started this almost a year ago
now we started putting the videos online
in January so let's see what our little
ho dome group is done in the process
here not nope that was wrong that's I
gave you a sheet with a time stamp on
when you're supposed to do it can you
just look at the sheet please bless her
heart she tries so hard so listen
actually doing the work listen we can't
help you with that you got to go out
there you got to get your hands dirty
right i mean if you're going to be
bailing hay you gotta bail hey you can't
get a machine to Bale the hay for you
because that ain't southern I can't help
you with that that's on you but the
complexity of the system now that's
something I can help with again trying
to get a bull stacked on top of a hand
stop inside of a barn just doesn't work
that way that's why this bald man on the
Internet's been you're handling so much
right the systems are so complex and
it's so difficult you know what it's
like it's like you getting a burger and
then asking the waitress what color the
bull was you can understand the
temperature of the meat right it don't
work that way you need somebody to sit
there and tell you how it's actually
going to work that's what these videos
have been doing so from our perspective
we got you covered there the complexity
of the system is all in the videos we've
been trying to explain it to y'all
people especially y'all from Oklahoma we
know he got some problems it's okay
we're going to take a little time
explaining to you the right way
from there though he got the complex
tools so you can understand what's going
on underneath the hood but you don't
know how the dadgum tools work because
it's a tennis sneaker or platinum my
graphics guy gave me that I actually
don't know what that would do is that is
that the smart boot Asher where's Asher
Asher is that the smart boot did we
copyright that logo no or is it a
trademark I forget is it someone someone
said it's a trademark no I'm southern so
the complex tools so what do we do with
that right well the good news is we've
got a whole great team dedicated to
actually letting you know how to use
these tools and they're on developers
android com we've gone through all of
the performance available tools and
tried to walk you through how to
actually use them to solve your problems
so if you combine the videos and tell
you what's going on under the hood and
you take a look at the tooling
documentation y'all should be able to do
this unless you from Oklahoma or
Louisiana sorry now the manual profound
part let's take a look at that here now
that's still a challenge I'm on MIT
that's that something Wayne got around
to fixing yet I mean it's only been
fifty three weeks at this point but we
have been making some good change this
assist traced to can I get a hell yeah
for systrace right now in this is tres
Tew we understand it's really hard you
got to go in there you got click the
buttons you understand what them little
fan down boxes are doing there but we
added something in there for you if you
don't know about see them little but
little tags up there at the top those
were words as you do a capture we're
going to analyze your frame information
and tell you what's going wrong in them
alerts now those pop up like ticks on a
mule deer right or
when you click on one of them down I
mean something I miss all now it's just
a mule deer down the field out here
everywhere is never never picked ticks
off a deer okay you click on one of them
it's going to tell you the bottom the
problem that we found and how you can go
fix it it's kind of like a runtime lint
right so we can help you take your
analysis and get a little more
automation and finding out where the
dadgum problems are go get a hell yeah
check can I get a hell yeah I'm gonna
make you wear two hat so we can't really
fix that but we're making strides there
so what about this difficult to repo
part that's actually a little complex
right because the issue is on the google
play console we can give you some really
good information but most of it's
catered towards crashes right some form
factor of Android development crashes
because some person actually tried to
use a duckbill to communicate with his
device and boom there you go we don't
really have a lot of good information
there with respect to how to repo
performance information that really hurt
my mouth to say that time formed johanna
rather thank you so we can't really do
that one now the different devices let's
let's get real here for a minute cuz cuz
we've and not real so far so I'm sure
you've all seen a picture like this on
the internet it's it's more popular in
them than Bieber pictures that are out
there now bless his heart he needs some
he needs some church as much as I can
say about that with my PR people
watching let's be honest about this yeah
there's a lot of form factors and this
is fan god damn tastic you all know why
because this allows your constituents to
get to your application at every
probably constituents know at every
price point and form factor that they
need individuals can make the
opportunity choice to figure out if they
want the quail smart boot or the three
million dollar phone in their hand this
is fantastic but it does create a prob
for you as an individual on what you
actually test your performance on so we
can't really help you with that either
but the good news is when you look at
these three things that we haven't been
able to solve is the Android performance
patterns initiative over the past year
hopefully some of y'all see a pattern
here right Oklahoma you see a pattern
ain't left yet so I'm guessing there
stay with me see those are pictures
moving on the screen so we love you
Oklahoma when you look at these you
realize that there's already a solution
out there from a technological advance
perspective that solves this and it is
called automated testing hell yeah for
automated testing raise your hand if you
use automated tests right now okay
that's all right whoa wait a minute put
y'all hands back up oh no why they all
sitting over here that's like that's a
Gaussian distribution of people who
actually test their damn code we're why
are you all just showing up late is that
what happened y'all y'all are the
preventative programmers Ryan y'all just
do this at hawk is that what's
going on here I just put some duct tape
on it and ship it will twill we're blame
the performance man infant Ryan that's
okay hell yeah we gonna go drinking
later boy the truth is that automated
testing solves this problem for you but
we got a problem with that is that
automated testing ain't never really
been applied to performance we do the
testing to be able to click it click of
the button button and figure out where
it crashes with the duckbill that's
that's a weird test I had to get a duck
and I had to like harness it in its all
quacking like right in your head you got
it you got it you can't tape it's bill
clothes cuz you have to feed it but you
can squat backpack but then you put on
one of them little dippers right there
and so he gets mad and starts pecking at
the screen if it put little feed
pictures on it and that's how we got our
testing done in the south I hope you all
got a bit you all bout a better version
that last what y'all use right that's
called duck testin hashtag hashtag duct
test
automated testing solves this but we
haven't had a chance to apply it to the
performance round I mean in reality this
is what you want right you want some
sort of automated UI test that can be
run through a bunch of different
scenarios and devices and provide for
you performance information now if you
had something like that what could you
do with it if you had the ability to run
continuous integration tests and get
performance data from it what could that
actually give you well first off you can
actually watch the performance health of
your application over time hell yeah
number two is you can figure out how
those performance metrics correlate to
money money by brian ferrill money no
ZZTop anybody am I too old for that sis
I see some beards longer than mine in
here I can't be that old although I do
have the least hair except for that guy
we're getting a beer later to you can
actually track how your performance
actually adheres to your mom tasted
monetization metrics and y'all love
money right hula a round of applause for
money round of applause from barbecue
Aaron I think me you may have a nice
barbecue money trade commission going on
here the nice thing you can also see is
how your memory on your device
fluctuates based upon the duck testin
you are changes so you can actually see
that clicking a button actually has
these ramifications of performance
across your environment and finally you
could actually be able when someone
actually submits a change list to be
able to tell them that they are stupid
because it actually cause performance
problems you could track that down right
to the exact CL in your github hell yeah
but again the problem is we don't have
this built which is why I am tickled
pink ladies and gentlemen to announce
today y'all going to build it
we got one of the fanciest code labs our
team could come up with at
twelve-fifteen you're all going to build
continuous integration environment for
performance for your applications hell
yeah she's trying too hard now it's it's
okay she did spend a little time in
Oklahoma although she is from Texas a
googler was stabbed to death today for
insinuating that someone from Texas was
from Oklahoma may he rest in peace but
the truth is we're not done there not
only y'all going to be able to go to
this code lab and build the environment
to test your apps in a performant manner
so you can make more money on the
backend and tell them people checking in
code they're messing with your
performance but we can't stop there
because there's still a fantastic amount
of different Android devices out there
that you need to run this code on and we
know that you can't get all them devices
in your pocket in your environment that
you're testing on on top of your desk
which why we got a second code lab today
about how to use Google Cloud test so
you can get your performance running
application in an automated environment
on the cloud can I get a hell yeah oh
you from Oklahoma hell no oh-oh we will
pray for you so it's gonna bring me to
my second topic today recovered
performance I wanna talk about something
else real quick I want to talk about
barbecue that's what we're here for
right I got to tell you as hard as
performance in barbecue is damn near
impossible now for those of us who've
been raised on Southern tradition you
know that barbecue is not just a cooking
process it's about community it's about
family it's about your cousin who you
know ain't right in the head but you let
them in your house on Sunday anyway
that's what barbecue is about it's about
coming together and I'll tell you what
over the past year what we've been doing
is trying to build one hell of a
community and I got to thank every one
of you in the room here today because
y'all been a part of that you all been
watching the videos you've been on the
Google+ community you've been using the
perf matters hashtag and I cannot tell
you how humbled I am that you're all
part of our barbecue thank you for that
but let's talk about something real
quick even though y'all wrong yeah yeah
if you got the shirt stand up stand up
stand up you got the shirt one two or
three rattle applause for these wrong
people bless their hearts bless their
hearts they came today despite these are
the cousins you invite to the barbecue
right there I just they just stood up
well done I got to tell you what this is
what I love more than ever y'all can
argue me so I'm pickled in the face
don't matter I will sit there and argue
with you happy happy happy as a cat on a
hot tin roof because this means you're
part of our barbecue it means you're
passionate enough about performance and
your codebase you're willing to argue
with a bald man on the internet and I
know how hard that is thank you for
being part of all this thank you for
being and loving performance and
everything we do so I got to tell you
from all the team that work on this it
ain't just me and then just one bald man
running around we got a whole team back
at google HQ I want you all give them a
round of applause because not all of my
hair drug this team works so hard in
getting these videos done the documents
done everything together they're the
ones to thank I'm just the great looking
man on the internet get to talk about it
hell yeah is that guy bald who said that
so with that I'm gonna let you all get
to the conference today we got a
fantastic goddamn conference when you
all go out there once you remember three
things number one number two
number three hey get some barbecue thank
you all very much
you